sammarinese benvenuti in un nuovissimo a
grande richiesta è tornato di gioco luna
[Musica]
[Applauso]
in particolare oggi continuiamo a
parlare di sé mogis super mega iper
inutili sì perché nell'ultimo video non
sono riuscite ad elencarle proprio tutte
quindi ci voleva per forza una seconda
parte di dillo con un emoji le emoji più
inutili di sempre
io partirei subito con le musiche mi
avete segnalato proprio voi proprio voi
mariners e io ho cercato di dargli un
senso anche se un senso non ce l'hanno
al primo posto quella che mi avete
segnalato veramente tutti è questa che
cos'è uno dei blues brothers che cos'è
il ballerino che sta volando sopra il
suolo
che cos'è un uomo senza piedi potrebbe
io ho trovato un nesso con la seconda e
musiche mi avete segnalato che il
tombino scoperto
ecco forse questo mino voleva tuffarsi e
cadere sprofondare nell'abisso degli
inferi della terra un tombino come
direbbe il biondo sto un attimo
viaggiando un'altra mohsin molto
enigmatica è questa questo signore non
si capisce bene cosa stia facendo
analizziamo insieme le varie opzioni
l'opzione numero uno è sta urlando forse
sta sputando sta fruttando o sta
agitando rimaniamo con questo dubbio
amletico passiamo alla segnaletica
perché non so se lo sapete ma tra i vari
segnali che abbiamo tra le voci ce n'è
uno che è veramente alto pericolo c'è
proprio dovete assolutamente fare
attenzione quando lo vedete perché è
veramente pericoloso e cioè questo
questo è ben attenzione bambino
gattonando per terra quindi non lo
pestate raccoglietelo possibilmente
prima che vada a finire nel tombino
aperto di prima passiamo all'ambito
religioso abbiamo infatti tra le nostre
mogi un rosario un rosario
credo buddista che non utilizziamo
solitamente nella nostra quotidianità ma
potrebbe essere il ritorno di una moda
che grazie a dio abbiamo passato da
qualche anno il rosario alcol nei
tronisti di uomini e donne
chi segue il programma sa che la canotta
bianca con il rosario era tendenza
allora chiaramente abbiamo tantissimi i
simboli giapponesi tra questi simboli ci
sono alcuni molto molto molto strani
tipo questa questa se andate a cercare
come si chiama è una flowers blaine card
cioè una carta da gioco fiore ha adesso
c è tutto più chiaro
e poi abbiamo lui vi leggo come si
chiama perché è un po difficile ma john
red dragon
ecco potrebbe essere il nome di un nuovo
ora ma chi di un ristorante fusion in
realtà è un emoji non si capisce cosa
simboleggi ma comunque passiamo alla
sezione tempo
sì perché mister e moggi voleva farci
avere tutti gli orari possibili
immaginabili non bastava un orologio che
simboleggiasse l'orologio o comunque
l'ora
ci volevano tutte le ore tutti i momenti
della giornata per non si sa mai che tu
vuoi dire mamma guarda arrivo alle 8 in
iv e sini metti invece di del numero 8 e
punto 15
il orologio delle emoticon in orari e
giusto
sempre parlando di tempo abbiamo due
modi praticamente identiche non capisco
bene cosa cambi però sono uguali e sopra
queste mosse c'è scritta una data
fondamentale che per un solo giorno uno
solo rasenta la perfezione perché il 16
luglio il mio compleanno e sopra c'è
scritto 17 luglio perché parquet 17 16
luglio o ricordate lo fate gli auguri a
questo l'ho chiamata la parentesi disney
adesso capirete perché perché tra le
varie voci nuove che ci ha regalato
mister emoji c'è la sirenetta
ma c'è anche il sirenetto che pare un po
strano però effettivamente esiste il
sirenetto esistono i sirenetti perché
nel film la sigaretta e pieno anche di
uomini con la coda quindi esiste ma la
cosa che non capisco e per quale motivo
è stata inserita la genio della lampada
sì perché tutti conosciamo aladin che ha
visto tutti dall'amico il film il genio
della lampada è maschio non si capisce
perché ci doveva essere anche la
versione femminile cioè per quale motivo
quando mai la dovremmo usare la genia
della lampada questo l'ho chiamata la
sezione igiene e adesso capirete perché
partiamo subito con queste mogi è un
piatto fumante è una tazza fumante o è
una scena puzzolente e questo è uno
scarico di gas o è una scoreggia e poi
arriviamo a loro loro secondo me sono
dei peli pubici
capelli pieni non lo so
in realtà vi vado a leggere cosa c'è
scritto nell'enciclopedia mondiale
internazionale delle muse trattino
ondulato e l'altro trattino riccio
apriamo i libri di storia ragazzi perché
dobbiamo rispolverare due antichi vasi
provenienti dall'antica grecia sto
parlando di queste due modi fantastiche
che non useremo mai nella nostra vita ma
che ci sono e sono lì per ricordarci una
pubblicità di un liquore di quando ero
piccola non so se esiste ancora con la
pubblicità al liquore penso di sì e
superando di questo negozio che cerca il
mare interno durate mesi
ora quell antico vaso andava portato in
salvo
sembrava impossibile mar ce l'avevamo
fatta
quanti ricordi ce la faccio benvenuti
alle previsioni del meteo per questa
settimana a questa rubrica è stata
curata dal colonnello giuliacci è
proprio de giuliacci vogliamo parlare
perché queste sono le cose più inutili
per quanto riguarda le emoji del meteo
sto parlando di queste musi a mister e
moggi non andava bene rappresentare con
una sola e modi il cielo lievemente
nuvoloso quindi con il sole e la nuvola
no lui ha voluto regalarci tutto il
processo di annuvolamento perché dalla
prima mogi con il sole era nuvola il
sole va sempre più indietro fino a
quando la nuvola copre il sole ed è
subito nuvoloso e dopo le nuvole arriva
la pioggia e mister emo xi chiaramente
ci ha voluto regalare questa fantastica
emoji dell'ombrello con la pioggia
perché solitamente l'ombrello si usa
quando piove ma proprio come il pupazzo
di neve senza neve non potevano
regalarci anche l'ombrello senza pioggia
così a caso aprire ombrelli e portarsi
sfiga
così senza un motivo passiamo alla
sezione mari e monti per quanto riguarda
il mare e andrea ad approfondire con voi
queste due modi perché c'è l'ombrellone
piantato sull'isolotto in mezzo al mare
ma c'è anche proprio come l'ombrello
l'ombrellone senza mare senza sabbia
senza sole così a caso qui adesso io
apro un ombrellone fine basta chiuso in
casa
passiamo al campeggio perché chiaramente
ci sono due tipologie etichette la tenda
nel bosco quindi con il pino dietro la
tenda con il nulla attorno perché si può
fare camping anche per strada e
concluderà il video con il momento
immobiliare perché abbiamo tante
tipologie di case tra le mogli
abbiamo la casa con la strada e l'altra
casa vicino abbiamo la casa
con l'albero dietro quindi mezza
campagna e abbiamo la casa senza nulla
intorno quindi che la possiamo associare
a qualsiasi tipo di paesaggio località
nazione ma la casa più affascinante più
crudi è questa la casa abbandonata
necessaria assolutamente tra le molle
perché noi tutti i giorni parliamo di
case abbandonate più che immobiliare
quest'ultima nota e artistica perché
chiaramente ci doveva essere un emoji
che rappresentasse un quadro ma
analizzerei con voi quest'opera d'arte
questo dipinto risalente all'ottocento
cosa c'è dentro aspetto curato un sole
una nuda questo è il disegno che facevo
sempre in prima elementare
siamo purtroppo giunti alla fine del
video fatemi sapere se vi è piaciuto e
soprattutto se avete qualche preferenza
per la prossima puntata di 2000 con una
nave se non siete ancora iscritti mi
raccomando iscrivetevi al mio canale e
soprattutto attivate la campanella che
trovate vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per
rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti i
miei nuovi video e soprattutto per
essere i primi a commentare se arrivavo
deve servirci su tutti gli altri social
facebook music hall e instagram mimando
una giovane ci vediamo al prossimo video
adoro ciao
[Musica]